[Music]
hey everyone I'm here with Laura Haas
and Laura welcome what's the area of
research that you're focusing on I'm a
database researcher from way back I
mostly look at how to get diverse types
of information together get it prepared
for data scientists to go get some
information about out of so what types
of research projects are you currently
involved in well my new gig is I am a
Dean so I'm not doing as much research
directly as I used to
but one of the things that I'm most
interested in right now is what they're
caught what we're calling computing for
the common good so how can we make
systems that not only can be used for
good purposes which we hope they will
you know cure disease and all the rest
of that but how can we make systems that
start to be good that have actually
embed some of the virtues that we would
think about as humans so they're fair
they don't discriminate in ways you
don't want them to discriminate they run
correctly they're helpful they're a
pleasure to interact with there's a lot
of different characteristics that might
come together to make a good system but
that's kind of what I found that my
faculty at UMass are really interested
in and so that's what we're trying to
encourage and and work through is there
a specific project with the faculty that
describes just that in terms of
computing for good well so one that's
close to my heart because it's also in
my areas one of my female faculty
Alexandre melio has been working with
others her colleague from software
engineering and others to see if they
can look at data and database systems
and make a database system that can tell
you whether your data is biased and help
you to avoid those sorts of mistakes
that we've had a lot of news stories
about recently where you know maybe a
black
couldn't qualify for a certain service
because there was discrimination by zip
codes or age discrimination or other
sorts of things where you can sort of
tell it these are the things I'm worried
about and it will check your data for
you and tell you whether you're going to
have a fair sample of the data and be
able to answer questions or make
decisions in a fair manner how do you
feel about attending the Microsoft
research faculty summit and what have
you learned - I've been learning a lot
I really everybody knows about Azur but
I learned a lot about what is work can
do and I had no idea about the explosive
growth that we've seen
I've enjoyed hearing about some of the
resources that I that Microsoft is
putting an open-source
I've sent notes to my faculty about for
example the Entrepreneurship panel
yesterday which was really great for
them we're trying to encourage more
entrepreneurship amongst our faculty and
students and so I sent a lot of people
notes going you know go watch this right
so yeah so it's just been a great couple
of days really really educational so
Laura what's one of the key pieces of
research that you see coming that will
drive disruption in the next five to ten
years as it pertains to systems so I'm
gonna go back to this whole thing about
good systems I don't I think that's just
starting we're hearing the fad phrase
which I hate and no fair accountable
transparent we're calling it equate the
idea that people will start paying as
much attention to what this is how the
systems work so that they they have some
principles to them and there's a better
chance that we will avoid the sorts of
mistakes that people are getting dinged
for so you know just as a for instance
we talked a lot about intelligent
systems
I want to hear us talking much more
about ethical sis
all right well Laura thank you so much
oh my pleasure
great talking to you
[Music]
[Applause]